let's do another one of these dependent
probability problems you have four coins
in a bag three of them are unfair and
that they have a 45 percent chance of
coming up tails when flipped the rest
are fair so for the rest of them you
have a 50% chance of tails or a 50%
chance of heads you randomly choose one
coin from the bag and flip it four times
what is the percent probability of
getting four heads so let's think about
it
when we put our hand in the bag and we
take one of the coins out there's some
probability that we get an unfair coin
and three of the four coins are unfair
so there's a three-fourths probability
that we are we get an unfair coin an
unfair coin and then there is only one
out of the four coins that's fair so
there was a 1/4 probability 1/4
probability that I get a fair coin
now given that I have so unfair let's
remind ourselves an unfair coin has a 45
percent chance of coming up tails so
this means that I have a 45 percent
chance of tails which also means we have
to be careful here because they're
asking us about heads if I have a 45
percent chance of getting tails that
means I have a 55 percent chance of
getting heads right whatever I have a
100 percent chance of getting one of
these two if it's 45 percent for tails
100 minus 45 is fifty five for heads for
the fair coin I have a fifty percent
chance of tails and a fifty percent
chance of heads 50 percent heads fair
enough now I want to know in either of
these scenarios what is a percent
probability of getting four heads
so if given I've got the unfair coin the
probability of getting four heads is
going to be fifty five percent for each
of those flips so the probability of
getting exactly four heads is going to
be it's actually going to be 0.55 times
0.55 times zero point five five times
0.55 and so the probability of picking
an unfair
coin and getting four heads in a row is
going to be equal to 3/4 times all of
this business over here so that's 3/4
times and this is 0.55 times itself four
times so I could write it as 0.55 to the
fourth power and we'll get the
calculator out in a second actually
calculate what this is now let's do the
same thing for the fair coin if I did
pick a fair coin the probability of
getting heads four times in a row is
going to be 0.5 times 0.5 times 0.5
times 0.5 or the probability of getting
the fair coin which is 1/4 probability
1/4 chance times the probability and
getting 4 heads in a row is going to be
1/4 times all of this so it's going to
be 1/4 times this is just 0.5 times
itself 4 times so that's 0.5 to the
fourth power so let's get the calculator
out to calculate either one of these so
we get 3/4 3/4 times and it knows that
when I do the multiplication it's not in
the denominator here so it's 3/4 it's
times and I'll just do it in parentheses
which I don't have to do in parentheses
because it knows order of operations so
0.55 to the fourth power is equal to
zero point let me write it down let me
take it off the screen so I can write it
down properly actually let me just do
both of these calculations so this
probability is that one right over there
and then this one down here is 1/4 times
0.5 to the fourth power so it's equal to
that right over there and so let's be
clear the probability the probability of
picking the unfair coin and then getting
four heads in a row is this top number
it's like six point roughly six point
nine percent chance that you get the
unfair coin and then get four heads in
the row the probability that you get the
fair coin and then get four heads in the
road
is even lower you it's only a 1.6
percent chance now the problem is
getting four heads in a row I either way
is going to be the sum of this and this
or the sum of that and that which is
going to be let me keep my calculator
out so it's going to be equal to I can
just take the previous ends
let me just retype it so I don't confuse
you so point zero one five six two five
plus point zero six eight six two nine
where's that two nine six eight seven
five six eight seven five I'm going to
round it anyway so it won't matter too
much so if I take the sum let me take
this off screen and then let me so I can
still see it and then let me write it so
what I got here this one is zero point
zero six eight six two nine and I'll
round at seven and this down here this
down here was zero point zero one five
six two five and when you add these two
up because we just care about getting
four heads either way this is the
probability of getting it this way with
the unfair coin this is the probability
of getting it with the fair coin we want
it either way so let's add the two which
we already did in our calculator so if
you add that number to that number you
get zero point zero eight four two five
and it keeps going but I'm just going to
round it so this is the same thing as
this is equal to eight point four two
five percent if I want to round it a
little bit more eight point four three
percent chance of getting four heads in
a row and once again that should be a
that's a slightly higher number then if
all of the coins were fair because
there's a there's a three fourth chance
that I get a coin that has a better than
even chance of getting head so that's
why this number is going to be a little
bit higher than the probability if I had
a fair coin of just getting four heads
in a row